we have uh Robin Lively we got Sean back
bring it in give me some sugar
[Music]
Mike come here
you took everything from me what was it
like shooting with with Sean and that
character sort of redemption Arc it was
great I mean he came in like every all
our OG guys uh uh come in and they just
do it a great job one of my favorite
scenes in episode 10 is outside the limo
and me knowing the insanity and and the
guys wanting to just uh get on the
horses and and yeah for a bigger throne
in my head I love that scene it's really
funny because Johnny has no nothing he
doesn't know this Mike Barnes is it
doesn't mean you know so who the hell is
this guy he's the battery that looks so
bad to me which is what what chosen says
as well
um but then he then Mike Barnes comes up
with his genius idea as far as Johnny's
concerned it's like you know the bad
boys right like all of a sudden he turns
around a time he's calling the bad boy
and they're you know they have no
history they have no bump it's
hysterical that these two these three
guys that tormented Larusso for all this
time are all all together
yeah I mean it's really fun it's a lot
of fun it's so fun to have that in the
show and ug just it knocks it out of the
park he's so it's so great to see this
you know
this villain upon villains from Karate
Kid Part Two now come back to be you
know a close friend and and an ally it's
it's it's just a tangled web it's so
much fun this is what we're up against
this is how everyone sees them as some
kind of philanthropist out to save the
kids of the valley Terry silver what was
the moment either in story pitches or
you know in whatever the process is
where you guys knew like well we're
raising the stakes this season this
season is going to be we're definitely
kicking it up a notch here in the early
part of the Season uh Daniel arusso is
the only one who knows the insanity of
what and who Terry silver is this cancer
of the valley and he kind of looks like
the crazy person goes off you know
off-road a bit and uh unravels all areas
of his life that was something that Dion
said I was excited about bringing forth
like him not so put together and just a
knee-jerk temper scenario he was he's
kind of losing his grip on everything
trying to do right so once once the team
all comes together and is this common
enemy and and uh and there there he
becomes the protagonist that he kind of
was in the original Karate Kid film uh
on the right side of the law for all the
right reasons um that was an exciting uh
thing for me and the Arc of the Season
uh you know that was different from the
previous Four Seasons yeah it's an
interesting Dynamic when Johnny Lawrence
is the one who's like what are you doing
what are you doing put it away that's
what I was gonna say I love that scene
that's the that's the that's that's when
the stakes get high for Johnny Lawrence
when he sees Daniel Larusso in such
distress it's like wait but there's
something really going on here and
Johnny's disconnected from it all he's
conveniently just put his Eagle Fang uh
you know headband down now um so when he
sees Lewis in this condition and then
also something happens to to Daniel that
is uh equally alarming and and um or
more alarming
so uh Johnny eases back into the fold
and sees it through
um for what it is for the first time and
and sees the stakes are higher in the
height meanwhile the stakes are being
being raised off screen by as far as
Johnny's concerned by silver and what's
going on in the valley as this is as the
dojo is as the dojo is spreading and
yeah uh and then it's like you know
Johnny opened that Pandora's boxes
Daniel says in one of the scenes and
Johnny feels like oh should I open that
I gotta I gotta help put it back in you
know yeah yeah and the I mean the the
fight scenes in this season are like
there's always been crying we've always
seen sort of like Johnny kind of street
fight a little bit but it feels like
everybody's street fighting this yeah
it's a little brawls
thank you
yeah yeah these are big bro yeah yes it
gets bigger and bigger yeah and we do it
on a a pretty tight budget and schedule
so you know props to all the the young
actors all all the actors across the
board and and delivering and delivering
that because they they're not writing
less of them that's no yeah no they're
getting they're like a guy losing a
finger there's I mean certainly in that
in the finale when the ultrasound falls
out of John's pocket when he's you know
it really seems like he's not gonna win
this fight I mean that's certainly like
is that in your eyes was that a moment
where we saw like this is this is
Johnny's sort of like not only
redemption in this fight but like as a
father as well like sort of
metaphorically he's not gonna let
anything take that away from him yeah I
mean and that was the moment where it's
like he realizes what he has to fight
for you know I mean if it's just that
Vendetta just fighting and there was
something bigger than him you know and I
think that's what that's where you know
where you win in a fight is when there's
something you're fighting for bigger
than yourself and so
um that is the the you know the
adrenaline shot that he needed to get
him off his beaten uh pulverized face
knees and get up and throw it again
getting throw down with the surge of
adrenaline
um which is which was super cool to see
what's gonna happen because as I'm
turning the pages I'm like okay so his
nose is broken fingers are broken lips
you know like okay whether is he dead
what happened so yeah that ultrasound
picture was was great with the finale
yeah um you know it ends on quite a
cliffhanger we learned that crease is
not only not dead he's escaped from
prison yeah
I'm begging you
for what
Mercy
[Music]
what do you guys want to explore next in
the next season is that the last of of
Terry silver and Cobra Kai as a dojo
one never knows I mean they certainly
have set up uh
uh this International world of of where
Cobra Kai was born
um halfway around the planet and and who
knows where that lands I mean all these
ideas are percolating in the The
Writer's room I don't have uh first-hand
knowledge of it all I know is these guys
keep thinking and they'll and know these
characters in this series uh and this
movie original movie better than we do
and so uh it's really exciting for us to
get the Christmas morning presents when
they start talking about where it can go
I can say this without spoiling anything
too is there's a lot of story that we
was written in that we shot that has
actually been yes not included in the
season yeah there was something a lot of
big stuff that is kicked down the field
that were that was edited out G moments
yeah yeah yeah things a whole to hold
till later which is a good sign that
means there will be more yeah there's
some I mean you know we hope there's a
design to everything here sir there's a
springboard to the next and uh yeah
that's happening in many directions
foreign